[Musique]
si les tendances démographiques récentes
se prolonger si l'état de santé de la
population continue de s'améliorer plus
de 65000 seniors serait en perte
d'autonomie en 2050 à la réunion soit
trois fois plus qu'en 2015 à la réunion
le fait marquant c'est un que là
la phase de vieillissement de la
population est en cours c'est encore en
cours en métropole mais simplement on
est en décalé par rapport à la métropole
est donc une grande partie du
vieillissement de la population est
encore devant nous dans les années qui
viennent et dans les décennies qui
viennent
et donc c'est encore un enjeu d'avenir
pour la réunion et puis le deuxième fait
marquant pour la réunion c'est que
la proportion de personnes âgées en
perte d'autonomie qui ont besoin des
aides pour les actes de la vie
quotidienne
la proportion est plus importante de ce
qu'on a en moyenne un état de santé pour
un âge donné qui est moins bon à la
réunion qu'en métropole environ un
senior sur cinq est en perte d'autonomie
soit perte d'autonomie modérée soit
sévère c'est des situations très
différentes
c'est le cas pour les femmes métropole
aussi c'est le cas pour les hommes mais
pour les hommes
leur état de santé moins bon en
métropole 3600 seniors en perte
d'autonomie vivre et en institution et
61 mille cinq cents à domicile
de fait 3800 emplois supplémentaires
seraient nécessaires
il y a un enjeu très important qui est
celui de l'emploi et donc des formations
parce que ne serait ce que sur les dix
quinze prochaines années il va falloir
3800 équivalents temps plein
supplémentaires
simplement pour les métiers qui viennent
en aide aux seniors en perte d'autonomie
il faut environ
[Musique]
un équivalent temps plein pour s'occuper
de deux personnes en moyenne en perte
d'autonomie sévère il faut en moyenne
une personne un équivalent temps plein
pour s'occuper de sept personnes âgées
en perte d'autonomie modérée
un défi pour le département chef de file
des actions à destination des seniors le
département met déjà en place
d
des solutions pour les années à venir
d'où la création de maisons d'accueil
liens familiaux
nous avons donc des ehpad qui voit le
jour au fur et à mesure nous avons
l'accueil familial comme je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure nous avons encore deux
cents places en accueil familial parce
qu'il faut pas oublier que la personne
âgée à la réunion
un temps à rester à domicile plutôt
qu'aller en cadets dans une institution
c'est pour ça que j'ai mis l'accent
aussi sur la situation des aidants
familiaux à la réunion d'ici 2050 de
mille deux cent nouvelles places en
institutions seront également
nécessaires
[Musique]